وغير الصراع بين امريكا والصين في صراع من
نوع ثاني انفتح صراع بين المؤمنين بوجود
كائنات فضائيه واللي مو مصدقين الكلام
امريكي لما تكلمت عن الاجسام الجديده اللي
اسقطتها سمتها
في العربي اجسام طائره مجهوله هذا المسمى
من عقود مرتبط بالحديث عن كائنات فضائيه
وهبوطه على الارض وفي معسكرات كبيره في
العالم مؤمنه انه هذا الشيء صار اكثر من
مره وانه في كائنات فضائيه نزلت قبل كده
على الارض فلما امريكا طلعت تكلمت عن
ثلاثه اجسام جديده طلع هذا المعسكر وقلك
هذا الظهور جديد للكائنات الفضائيه
واستندوا في كلامهم على تصريح لجنرال
امريكي ما استبعد هذا الاحتمال ابدا
فيديو
انشطه لكائنات فضائيه
طبعا سمعنا الصحفيين بيضحكوا في القاعه
وكتار يمكن يضحكوا بالموضوع لكن حقيقي هو
ذرى الموضوع جدا حقيقي جدا والصراع هذا
حقيقي وبامانه التصريح ما فرق كثير
والصراع لسه قائم واعتقد راح يفضل قائم
لسنوات طويله بين المؤمنين قطعا بانه في
كائنات فضائيه وبين المشككين يعني يمكن
اسهل طريق الحسم الموضوع هذا وحسم الجدل
لو موجودين الجماعه ينزلوا ويظهروا
ويخلصون عادي ويشيلونا معاهم خلاص بعد
كورونا تبلد احساسي انا
[موسيقى]